[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime ganic est célibataire
vous avez énormément de succès maxime
c'est vrai non mais franchement vous le
sentez ça ou pas avec les filles ça se
passe bien mais ça se passe très bien
adresse bien léger les messages vraiment
très bienveillant de plein de personnes
qui veulent que ça y boire un verre avec
elle à ouidah mais même j'en ai un peu
trop donc moi qui n'a jamais été le le
coeur de l'attention va sorti avec une
fille depuis six mois ouais c'est sûr le
mag ouvre une petite annonce pour vous
oui essentiel d'une parodie au départ
j'ai fait la parodie des des princes de
l'amour et on a émis une adresse mail
ouais véritable de la semaine et je
crois que vous avez beaucoup de demandes
croissance pour son mail à 300 messages
pour vacciner et d'un maxi je vous
demander de partir quoi ce plateau vous
allez partir de ce plateau parce que
votre vie va changer ce soir maxime
allez-y on va vous venir en chercher bas
venait le chercher
maxime d'elisa d'aller dans un endroit
dans lequel votre vie va changer
maxime gagnon va le retrouver dans un an
il va prendre une moto et que vous allez
voir on va le retrouver et je relance
bonadio bois de boulogne
[Rires]
votre vie va changer
et regardez maxime gainey il est arrivé
à l'endroit où ils devaient être maxime
est ce que tu m'entends mon maxime est
ce que tu manges
maxime commerces avaient une magnifique
villa pour maxime gagny avec toutes les
jeunes filles qui nous écrit non voilà
trois ans j'ai passé toutes des jeunes
chez qui nous écrit mais en tout cas il
a l'air d'avoir une très bonne ambiance
regardez maxime gagne arrive à la baisse
la haye faudrait plus le son les chéris
ouais
tashi match même match parce que vous
êtes content maxime venir
[Applaudissements]
maxime est ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous allez donner le bouquet
de fleurs à la jeune fille qui est au
bout du pont là bas attendez
maxime reculer d'abord avant de la voir
et avec voulu passer un petit poème
la dame est restée sur le pont elle
aurait voulu forcer un petit poème il
faudrait dix ans alors qu'elle venait de
se calmer merci alors c'est l'instant
poèmes aujourd'hui je suis content de
t'entendre je suis content de te voir tu
es aussi belle que la rosée du matin
toutes les femmes de ma vie aujourd'hui
rio dit tuez les chéris de maisons vie
et grâce à toi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le grand soir mais cette jeune
fille elle est très mignonne franchement
très mignonne demandé le maillot deux
pièces c'est juste parfait
demandez lui même et vous chers de
moselle j'adore jacques athlètes
est ce qu'être de l'amour et autres
merci vous en dis des conneries
oui ça m'arrive ouais maxime est ce que
vous voulez aller la rejoindre ou est-ce
que vous préférez rester de l'autre côté
du pont là vous savez là je pense qu'on
est à une dizaine de mètres
j'ai des roses d'une grande qualité la
sent bon ça sent la route et je vais les
lévisiens vous la portez avec coeur à
l'aller amour fraternel pour l'instant
mais j'avais demandé à la jeune fille
est ce que vous voulez qu'ils viennent
nous rejoindre
jade elle n'attend que ça et bien
allez-y aller en cours
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
radicaux peuple
regardez regardez comme il est heureuse
n'allez pas me voiler n'allait pas bleu
noyer sa maxime st cyr est ce que
voulait revoir leur ip quand même ballot
et paient pour ceux qui le regarde et on
va revoir attendait c'est magnifique à
lise ou bombe a écouté a beau la vie
c'est pas c'est pas aujourd'hui qui m'a
fait chaud merci merci allez c'est bon
il va revenir au maxime bono boîte sport
qu'on n'aime pas ça la maxime
il est l'union il est beau il est beau
gosse je les adore ce mec
[Musique]